[Music]
hello again time then for the press
preview it's a first look at what is on
sunday's front pages and tonight we'll
see what's making the headlines with the
journalist and author christina
patterson and the political editor of
the scottish son rachel watson a very
good evening to both of you we'll chat
in a moment first of all let's uh have a
look at those front pages for you we'll
start with the observer shall we
focusing on biden's warsaw speech and
his assertion that the butcher putin
cannot be allowed to stay in power
while the telegraph also leads with
biden's speech echoing the line for
god's sake this man can't remain in
power
the express reports on the cost of
living crisis with a warning to the
chancellor and the prime minister that
they risk losing the next election if
they fail to deal with it
the mirror takes a look at william and
kate's stance on the commonwealth with
their statement let the people decide
and the star also puts the spotlight on
the royal family with a story on a
naturist cruise celebration of the
queen's jubilee
and just remind you by scanning the qr
code you can see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages
as we discuss them and we are joined
tonight by christina patterson and
rachel watson uh so lots to
talk about uh and why don't we start
rachel with uh that speech by president
biden in warsaw a little earlier uh it
was a very powerful speech i mean the
president has come under some criticism
over the last few weeks about his
handling of this crisis uh front page of
the sunday telegraph quoting him for
god's sake this man can't remain in
power talking about putin of course what
did you make of it
yes as you say this was in some ways a
very powerful speech from president
biden those words around for god's sake
this man can't remain in power i felt
like it was a big shift in the stance
that the us government has taken in
recent weeks and months was this for
example as is suggested in some of the
stories that the the us were pivoting
and saying that there should be a regime
change in russia and which the white
house have come out afterwards and you
can see it in those stories the line
from the white house is that that's not
what president biden was calling for
that's not what he meant when he said it
so it sounded very much like he was
calling for a regime change the pr
vladimir putin should not be in charge
but the white house have walked this
back slightly and we can also see that
reaction from the kremlin where they've
hit back again and because
we see this war of words and it's
another ramping up of that between uh
nato allies and russia again and but
despite the speech being powerful there
was a lot of language in there he
referred to
putin as a butcher and there's also been
some unhappiness and i've read some of
the reaction from ukrainian politicians
who felt actually there was a lot of
words there was a lot of warm words and
harsh language in it but actually there
was very little promise to them so they
want to win this war they don't just
want it to end they want to win this war
and they felt that there was very little
in there pledges made by biden for
weapons for example and what more the
u.s could do and i think they'd hoped
that this speech at the end of his visit
to poland would really be able to kind
of
push forward and see what the u.s were
going to do how the u.s are going to
help ukraine in this um pivotal moment
because it seems like the war is going
to stretch out even longer than anybody
could have predicted and they were
looking for a little bit more so i've
been reading some of that reaction as
well which isn't really in the papers
i've seen but i think it's important to
reflect back on that yeah you make a
very good point uh the front of the
observer also quoting uh uh biden saying
uh butcher putin cannot be allowed to
stay in power what do you think about
that christina i mean ukrainians need
more than just rhetoric don't they
yes the ukrainians do need more than
rhetoric but of course the
horrible
dilemma that any country faces is
putin's threat
of escalation and that's what the holy
ghost is trying to avoid at the moment
and it's agonizing i think it's
agonizing for anybody watching what's
happening in ukraine and seeing the
atrocities that are being carried out
there on a daily basis which does look
very much like genocide and very very
clearly war crimes but it remains the
case that if we put troops if the west
puts troops into ukraine and or even
supplies uh
air cover um
then that is
that will be seen as
joining the war and then you are talking
world war iii so it is a really
agonizing situation and i can see that
biden is in a very difficult situation i
think part of what we saw in that speech
earlier was the kind of passion that he
used to show when he talked about
apartheid for example that campaigning
politician that passion
is coming out and in a sense maybe it is
misplaced because to be seen to be
calling for regime change i mean in this
mad world where anybody saying thinks of
course russia needs a different regime
of course it needs a different leader
because
putin is leading russia into disaster
it's leading into it into pariah
state status it's leading it into
economic nightmares and it's using its
young men
many of them barely children
as cannon fodder and many many many
russian mothers have already we don't
know if it's 10 000 or 15 000 but by the
time this thing ends it will be many
many more the sacrifices for apparently
nothing are absolutely
enormous but to be seen to be calling
for regime change
of course plays into the kremlin's
playbook as well because that's exactly
their point that the west is anti-russia
and it feeds into their narratives and
their propaganda so i think one could
argue that even though no sane person
would think it that putin should stay
one could argue that it is actually a
gaffe on putin's part on
joe biden's part to say this yeah i mean
this is rather strange it was clearly a
scripted speech he was reading it from
auto queue um it obviously all been
approved and then and then the white
house have to roll back slightly on on
those comments um let's leave that there
and move on to mata's um back home front
of the sunday
express rachel solve the cost of living
crisis or you'll lose
the election the fallout from the the
mini budget still on many of the uh
front pages
yes so the sunday express they've got a
poll that they've done and it's found
that 63 of people don't think that the
chancellor went far enough with his
spring statement mini budget as you say
and there's a lot of criticism of rishi
sunak after this announcement and what
the government and when the chancellor
was delivering this announcement making
a speech in the commons he had these big
pledges or what he thought were big
pledges pulling the rabbit out of the
hat that would be widely welcomed so for
instance they cut to income tax and the
rise raising the threshold for national
insurance contributions these were
things that got him a lot of cheers in
the commons but actually the whole point
of this was that we are going through a
cost of living crisis now there are
families who desperately need help now
and neither of these kick in immediately
so the income tax
cuts they won't kick in until 2024 by
2024 the national insurance contribution
threshold rise isn't until july so
that's three months of this the rise in
national insurance contributions people
will have to pay before it's then offset
so i think there's been a lot of
criticism there that he didn't go far
enough there was nothing in there to
support people in universal credit
either so there's been this criticism
and i think this poll just really shows
how widespread that feeling that the
government didn't do enough and aren't
doing enough despite this crisis that
has gone on with so many families up and
down the country impacted by rising
costs of energy bills fuel and what they
buy in the shops prices are going up and
this really just puts that in there it's
also got a figure that's 67 percent of
people um are struggling with heat and
energy costs at the moment so it shows
that this is such a massive issue and it
feels like that the chancellor took a
bit of a wrong turn during the week he
didn't do what was being asked of him
yeah christine is it fair do you think
do you think the british public do put
all of this on the chancellor's
shoulders given that he was dealt a very
difficult hand wasn't he you know
inflation going up the pandemic the
energy crisis the ukraine war
all issues that weren't of his making
well what was what was of his making was
the statement he made and the measures
he's announced which are absolutely
pathetic i think we saw rishi sunak's
true colours this week actually he
managed to present himself during the
early stages of the pandemic as mr nice
guy with his furlough measures and so on
and he managed to project himself as a
kind of compassionate nice person and
what we've seen this week is
breathtaking cynicism cynicism one might
almost say johnsonian cynicism because
this statement was designed for one
group well two groups actually tory
backbenchers and tory party members with
an eye on
his leadership chances and it was not
designed for the public good or for the
good of the british people let's be
clear this is going to plunge people
into poverty i mean to call it the cost
of living crisis is actually kind of
euphemistic it really really underplays
a scale of the problem i opened a batch
of bills the other day and thought oh my
god this is a nightmare you know i will
be okay but there are many many people
in this country who won't be okay and it
really will be a choice between heating
and eating and that's become a bit of a
cliche but the escape we've heard
reports this week and people talking
people with three jobs who said they're
having to choose between having the
heating on and feeding their children i
mean this is kind of the kind of poverty
we haven't seen in this country for a
long time i think when it really hits
people are going to be desperately
shocked and upset and what what rishi
sooner offered this week was was
absolutely insulting to the british
people of course he could have done more
he was clinging on to his thatcherite
ideological small state view and it's
just not up to the challenge okay uh
matt's cartoon in the telegraph
uh so good as always price promise
everything cheaper than it will be very
soon uh he says to a
shopper there rachel just in one
sentence is that fair what christina has
said that this this mini budget wasn't
designed for the good of the british
people
i think there's a real feeling that this
budget doesn't do what it was what
people wanted it to do and i think
there's a lot of frustration
out there and we've seen that you know
he made the speech and it was going down
well as christina said with toy mps in
the chamber but as soon as that speech
was finished there was um you know a lot
of concern a lot of frustration from
various people that the government need
to look at this again and come back with
more okay all right we will leave that
there thank you both very much coming up
the duke of cambridge's surprising
statement on the final day of his
caribbean tour discussing that in a
couple of minutes
[Music]
welcome back part two of the press
preview christina and rachel still with
us uh rachel front page of the observer
international nurses in the uk are
forced to pay up if they quit explain
this to us
so this story is as you say about
international nurses who have been hired
from abroad
and in their contract there is a
stipulation that if they leave this job
and they they want to move to something
else or return home they will have to
pay back
money that was used in that hiring
process so
for things like um
travel for example and other things
around their hiring process they've been
asked to pay that back and there's a
figure in there of up to fourteen
thousand pounds that nurses are
facing and if you leave i think i found
the story um quite shocking actually
it's understandable why um
the comments from president biden are
the splash on the paper so it's on the
front page which is great and i find
that the detail in this particularly
shocking um around what you know these
people have come to the uk to do these
jobs work for nhs trusts it's not just
private companies they're talking here
and they're being given these really
quite um harsh demands that should they
leave and within a time frame they will
have to pay this back and that's an
investigation that's been done by the
observer and something they've been
looking into
yeah and christina designed to to keep
staff on and and get back some of the
recruitment costs but uh you know they
could end up with huge debt
i thought it was really shocking i mean
i think in a way it's bad enough
poaching nurses from other countries
where they're often needed much more and
often where they've been trained in
their own countries and then uh and are
much needed but we lure them with what
are the probably higher wages here not
very high but probably higher than in
their home countries and then to saddle
them with all these extra costs i think
is really shocking and we mustn't forget
that during the pandemic the strain
still continues in many hospitals and
and for nurses
and doctors but
you know nurses the the stress of
working day in day out in in sort of
busy covered boards was absolutely
dreadful and many i've met nurses who've
suffered post-traumatic stress disorder
from the time they spent during the
pandemic so i think it's a really really
shocking way to treat people who who've
given all that time and energy and
effort for in the service of this
country yeah shocking yeah i just want
to move on very quickly because we're
running out of time to the royal story
front page of the mirror wills let the
people decide it's been quite the tour
uh this one hasn't it rachel and uh his
comments today are fascinating um
talking about the commonwealth and he
he's sort of accepting that he may well
not be ahead of it one day
yeah and i was just reading some um
posts on twitter and some um reaction
from royal commentators who were saying
that this was an unprecedented statement
from prince william over the last couple
of days he's made a number of statements
or speeches on the tour and from what i
understand it's been very tightly
guarded what he's going to say and it
was in the paper that these were last
minute comments there was changes made
to his speech at the last minute and i
think as you say he's reflecting on that
tour and reflecting with the times where
we are in the times and what people want
he's been listening to people in the
bahamas in belize about what they want
from the past what they want us to look
back on and recognize and those horrors
that that happened then but also what
they want from their future and whether
they want to be part of the commonwealth
and there did seem to be an acceptance
in here from prince william that you
know this is not his decision to make
it's not the royal families it's not the
institution but it's actually the people
and if they decide that they don't want
to be part of the commonwealth this
seems to be fully accepted
christine a very quick thought from you
on this
yeah i think good for him i think he's
very good at tone prince william and i
think he's he understands that times are
changing i think he's absolutely serious
about both about his job and about black
lives matter and many of the issues that
have come up uh quite recently and of
course intensely aware of the shameful
legacy of slavery which is always going
to be the elephant in the room when
you're when you're going on on tours
like this so i think he's handled it
very well i think some of the optics
have been dreadful i mean really kind of
colonial pictures
presumably not particularly his fault
but i think he was absolutely right to
say this and good on him and you know
this stuff is really outdated and of
course it has to be their choice and and
that's just a fact so it's good that he
stated it with grace and dignity we must
leave it there uh thank you both very
much